Speaker 1: Let's talk about the right's sick,
depraved obsession with a guy named Hunter
Biden. Now, I know many of you are evaluating and
thinking about how has the presidency of Joe Biden
gone? Has he done good things? Has he done bad
things? Has he not done enough things or is he
doing too much? Is his perspective on gun safety
the right perspective? We're talking about the
president. There is a large swath of people and
many of them are in positions of power. Many of
them are people who have large microphones, some
literally large and some proverbs, metaphorically
large microphones who are obsessed not with Joe
Biden. They're not alone with Joe Biden, but with
a guy named Hunter Biden. Now, Hunter Biden has
no role whatsoever in his father's administration,
simply none. It's not like Jared Kushner or
Ivanka who were involved in their father's
and father in law's administration. Hunter is
not trying, nor does he have any role in Joe
Biden's administration. And yet. There are many
on the right who are obsessed with him. There
is a really good article which we will link
to in the description to the YouTube video
call by Michael Tomasky for New Republic. It
was published yesterday called There Is Nothing
Stranger Than the Right's Fixation with Hunter
Biden. Now, the article is excellent. It depends
how you want to interpret this, but on the one
hand, it is a bizarre hyper fixation on Hunter
Biden from the right. On the other hand, it's also
kind of not. And we're going to talk about that.
The sort of catalyst for this article, which
I encourage you to read, was the Twitter files
bombshell that flopped over the weekend, a Twitter
thread published by journalist Matt Taibbi.
And a couple of important things to highlight
here. The article reads What exactly is at the
root of the Right's Hunter Biden obsession?
At its simplest level, the Hunter saga is just
a potential Achilles heel for a president they
want to defeat in 2024. Assuming Joe Biden runs,
I think that. That's right. I think that
they don't really care about Hunter Biden.
In and of itself. But they care about Hunter
Biden as a possible way to hurt Joe Biden in 2024.
But that has never quite explained. The
article goes on the manic quality of
the drive to turn Hunter into the symbol and
standard bearer of the Democratic Party and of
liberalism generally. It had to have something
to do. I always thought, with the notion that
Hunter represents the licentiousness with which
conservatives associate liberals, his drug use,
his sketchy affair with his dead brother's
wife, and now his entry into the effect and
vaguely un-American Manhattan art world.
But this weekend, things got even weirder
and in ways that were so sordid, it took me
a while to even understand what was going on.
If you had the good fortune or sense not to crawl
down this particular rabbit hole over the weekend,
fear not. I won't drag you into the depths that I
descended. The briefest recap is this. On Friday,
Elon Musk tweeted he would reveal how Twitter
supposedly covered up the Hunter Biden scandal
in October 2020. Matt Taibbi posted some of the
emails found on Hunter's hard drive. Some showed
the Biden campaign asking Twitter to refrain from
posting certain material. That's basically it.
In some quarters of the right, this is
the biggest scandal in the history of the
republic because it allegedly proves that Biden
used his governmental power. He, by the way,
didn't control any of the government at the time
to set fire to the Constitution. Musk tweeted,
If this isn't a violation of the Constitution's
First Amendment, what is? There are a couple
different things that I believe are
important to mention here. First of all,
if we want to go back to the source of all
of this, the Hunter Biden laptop itself.
What's, in a sense ironic is that everything
there that definitively touches Joe Biden makes
Joe Biden look really good. What I mean by that
is that there are lots of allegations the right
makes about the Joe Biden connection. They say,
well, when the messages refer to the big guy
getting a cut, it's about Joe Biden. There is no
evidence of that at this point in time. Could it
be true? Sure. There is no evidence of that at
this point in time. The things we know relate to
Joe Biden that we have uncovered based on these
emails are that Joe Biden really loves Hunter.
That Joe Biden really expressed empathy
for hunters drug use and and drug problems,
etc.. The voice message where he says, It's Dad, I
called to tell you I love you. The right tried to
make this frame Biden as being weak. The truth is,
don jr probably wishes his dad talked to him that
way and told them he loved him. That relationship
doesn't really seem quite so good. But the truth
is that everything we definitively have linked to
Joe Biden from the laptop makes him look pretty
good. And the reality is that conservatives
don't really have the indictment of Joe Biden
anywhere that exists of Trump. And that's why
they are making it all about Hunter Biden. And
in his article, Michael Tomasky eventually gets
to this exact conclusion. The Hunter crusade,
he writes, is thus driven not only by pursuit of
scandal to hang around his father's neck. It is
rooted in the right's antique and cruel value
system, which most Americans no longer share.
Should Republicans catch Hunter in some genuinely
corrupt or illegal arrangement? So be it. Let him
pay his debt to society. If they don't, they will
be left wondering why America doesn't share their
seething hatred of a man whom the Jesus they
claim to worship would have counsel dust to
regard with compassion. This is fundamentally
what this is all about, and there's two sides
to this now to get back to the bizarre nature of
the obsession. On the one hand, it is bizarre.
They're obsessed with someone so meaningless, not
as a person. Every person has value meaningless in
the context of figuring out is the country
going in the right or wrong direction?
What policies of Joe Biden's have been helpful
versus damaging to the economy or to foreign
policy or whatever? It's meaningless in that
sense, and that is bizarre. But at the same time,
hyperfocus on irrelevant issues has been
the name of the game for this Republican
Party. Four for six, probably more like
eight or even closer to ten years at this
point in time. And that really shouldn't
surprise us at all. The David Pakman Show
is a community funded program. It's funded by
the audience through the membership program.
You can find out about the membership program and
of course, sign up very, very quickly and easily.
At join pacman dot com. You can also use the
coupon code 24 starts now to get yourself a
discount. Members get access to the daily
bonus show, an extra show we do every day for
our members. You also get commercial free audio
and video streams of the show. Invitations to
the members only town hall events and much
more. You can sign up at join Packman dot com.